hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar pediatric genetics
applications of NGS and clinic on Judy
O'Rourke of lab roots and I'll be
moderating the session today's web
seminar is presented by lab roots the
leading scientific social networking
website and provider of virtual events
and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning let's get
started this is an educational webinar
and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over and to get your credits click on
the button located in the bottom left
hand corner of your web page you can
post questions to the speaker during the
presentation while they're fresh in your
mind to do so simply type them in the
Q&A box which will open when you click
the green to an a button at the lower
left of the presentation window
questions will be answered after the
presentation to enlarge the slide window
click on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you experience technical problems seeing
or hearing the presentation just click
on the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
green Q&A button at lower left I now
present today's speaker Emily Farrell
PhD director of laboratory operations of
the Center for pediatric genomic
medicine at Children's Mercy Hospital
dr. phero joined the center as a
research scientist in February 2012 she
is an assistant professor at the
University of missouri-kansas city
school of medicine and has a secondary
appointment at the Indiana University
School of Medicine in the department of
medical and molecular genetics dr.
Farrell tained a master's in genetic
counseling from the Indiana University
School of Medicine followed by a PhD in
molecular genetics she has completed a
postdoctoral fellowship supported by a
National Kidney Foundation research
grant in a phosphate regulation at
Indiana University School of Medicine
dr. Farrell is also a board-certified
genetic counselor her research interests
include metabolic bone disorders in the
role of genetic counseling in genomic
medicine dr. Farrell will now begin her
tation thank you very much for asking me
to give this presentation I'm happy to
share a little bit about our Center and
how we're using genomic sequencing you
bring up my slides again I'm going to
talk about pediatric genetics and
specifically how we're applying this in
our clinic and some of our research
applications a little bit of background
about our center the center for
pediatric genomic medicine at Children's
Mercy was actually is a relatively new
center and we were established in
January of 2011 and at the time we were
one of the first pediatric genomic
centers fully immersed within a
pediatric hospital mr Center is rapidly
enlarging as you might expect and were
made up of a large team and essential
people of directors such as myself over
the laboratory medical directors and
violent / Maddox with research
coordinators and we have an entire
informatics team that supports us that
I'll talk about we have positions that
we work with throughout the hospital and
then also as you might expect we have
essential collaborations with our Center
for Bioethics in our clinical genetics
program and really it takes a whole
village to run a genome center so one of
the things I want to spend a few minutes
on and the presentation is just giving
some contexts about the human genome and
a next-generation sequencing in general
because I think if you have a basic
foundation it makes it much easier to
understand different types of testing
and how they're being applied otherwise
some of the words can quickly become
Greek and not make much sense so to keep
it
perspective the human genome is 3.2
billion base pairs or that's 6.4 billion
nucleotides and if you're going to copy
that yourself manually that would be
equal to typing 60 words a minute a day
eight hours a day for 50 years so we
think about what our bodies are able to
do it's amazing now of those 3.2 billion
base pairs only about nine there's only
about 19,000 genes so this is one to two
percent of the genome so we're still
working on understanding what the rest
of the genome the other ninety eight
percent is doing but those nineteen
thousand genes are coding at least a
hundred thousand proteins and these
numbers change a little bit I feel
almost monthly whether there's more or
less genes but this is a pretty good
number that's been fairly stable so one
of the things to think about too is the
relationship of frequency and size and
the types of genomic variants and this
also helps when you're looking at
testing that you might order on the
clinic so this chart is just showing you
that structural changes happen least
often so this is where we have
chromosomal rearrangements duplications
or try soumise but they cover the
biggest space because they are so big
then if you move to the next smaller we
have copper number copy number variants
and this is where really we've seen
microarray be especially informative so
this is where we're looking at big gains
or losses within a chromosome we they
are going to a little bit smaller
insertions and deletions so there can be
snipper raised there's also recently
been the development of exon arrays and
these will give you deletion and
duplication information on an exon by
Exxon basis with in jeans and then for
genomic sequencing really what we're
focusing on here are some of the small
urban areas so single nucleotide
variants and while they are the smallest
variants if you look at the number of
nucleotides they happen most frequently
throughout the genome and this has been
the bread and butter of genomic
sequencing and really will continue to
be for the near future and so this is
one of our favorite closer descriptions
when we think about next-generation
sequencing and how that's that's being a
part of personalized medicine and
genomic medicine is really a new
structured approach to disease discovery
diagnosis and management that's
prominently featuring these
next-generation sequencing techniques in
and the title of this was charting a
course for genomic medicine from base
pairs of bedside do you think we're
really now at the customer really
realizing how genomic medicine is
changing our clinical management and
it's just an exciting time so
traditionally when you think of genetics
and the way that it's been done in the
past is that we had sang or PCR and
that's where we were doing gene by Gene
exon by exxon sequencing and so what
would happen is that a patient were
coming to clinic and we would look at
them we do a very detailed phenotypic
assessment to see what clinical features
does this patient have and then I think
this is most representative of this
disease so an example might be a patient
that comes in with multiple fractures
resync rush they really look like they
might have osteogenesis imperfecta so
we're going to order collagen 1a1 screen
that's a big gene so it would take a
while now in some cases you can do
multiplexing listing or PCR and that
accommodates small panels these are
still time consuming and they're really
limited to known genes so you have to
know where to look in order to do this
type of sequencing the plus side and why
this is still called the gold standard
in many cases is that sang or PCR
sequencing is very precise so if we look
at a patient and we know where to look
for that change we can see here that
they're heterozygous for a change and if
we look in our control or negative
control their homozygous for the
reference and so it's very clear that
there's a change a heterozygous changing
this person we're seeing a shift and
what next-generation sequencing is is
that these are technologies that permit
rapid interrogation of DNA up to and
including entire genomes being massively
parallel sequencing and this is really a
term that emphasizes distinction from
the initial approaches that involve
sequencing of one DNA strand one gene 1
X amount of time and because we've seen
this rapid decrease in cost and a rapid
decrease in time it's creating a
paradigm shift in the approach to
monogenic disease particularly so I
mentioned that our Center was one of the
first Center is fully immersed within a
pediatric hospital and I think there's
lots of reasons of why next-generation
sequencing and genomic medicine is
particularly applicable and children
and there's some hard facts to that and
that's because currently there are over
8,000 suspected genetic inherited
diseases but they're affecting one child
in 30 in the United States they cause
one in six children's hospital
admissions and they actually can cause
up to twenty percent of infant deaths
that's really significant when we're
looking at our health care population we
look at those eight thousand suspected
genes or diseases we only know the
molecular basis for about 4,700 of those
so we still have almost 3,000 gene or
inherited sin roads where we don't know
the cause or the underlying molecular
diagnosis and this means that a
diagnosis can still often take years for
a family I think we all can agree that a
delayed diagnosis may delay appropriate
treatment it may allow a disease to
worsen and it can hurt a family and that
not knowing the cause is very
frustrating and can be hard and it also
can cost money not that that's the
important factor but it's costing money
and time and tests ordered and clinic
visits trying to figure out what the
answer is so this has been something
that we've seen over and over and I'll
show with case examples that we're now
seeing a shift the part of this paradigm
shift is that before we are really based
on a fancy big driven diagnosis and
we're replacing that with a genotypic
diagnosis and next-generation sequencing
is what's enabling us to make the
diagnosis of these atypical
presentations that you maybe would have
never considered otherwise that gene or
gene and family so I'm in genomics on
part of the center obviously of them
running the lab and still to me to this
day often times it can be overwhelming
the number of sequencing options we have
that can be used both in a research and
clinical basis and so what are the
projects that we're doing on how
sequencing being drunk save this cartoon
summarize is it really well I can be
just overwhelming at beginning and so
clinically we have three main buckets
that we're using it on for our testing
that I want to go over and and really
highlight how we're next-generation
sequencing is being applied in changing
our practices so one is a targeted panel
called tag scan that we developed it
includes 571 genes these are mostly
autosomal recessive pediatric onset
games are a few very common autosomal
dominant again such as the college and
James 40 I and this includes the
mitochondrial genome as well we also
have X dome sequencing so that we're
offering on both the research and in a
clinical basis and again whole exome
sequencing is going to cover all of the
19,000 known genes and this is going to
sequence every X on of those jeans we
also supplement and include the
mitochondrial genome this has been
really good for novel disease discovery
and none of our medical mysteries and
then we also is a center offer clinical
whole genome sequencing for our patients
and we also have simple genome
sequencing on a research basis and you
may have heard of our stat seek which is
our rapid protocol that I'll go over and
I think this is really highlighting the
intersection of research and clinical
and how that line is becoming grayer and
blurrier all the time so when it's been
a few minutes on how a next-generation
sequencing works the technology because
it'll make much more sense to you than
with the difference between a targeted
panel and XO minute genome I'm so just
briefly sample from the sample
preparation for next gen well there are
subtle differences between the tests and
they're basically follow the same
procedure and one of the critical things
is that all samples undergo library
preparation and really the goal of this
library preparation is to add our
sequencing primers and also we add
barcodes to identify individuals so
similar to a UPC symbol you might see in
the grocery store where bar coding our
sample so that we can know who that DNA
belongs to and also so we can mix them
downstream together another thing I want
to point out that for short read
sequencing this process involves
fragmenting DNA and so this is called
this is where the term shotgun
sequencing comes from because we take
the DNA and we break it out to a lot of
pieces just like we hit it with a
shotgun it and broke it up to thousands
of pieces and this is a picture of one
of the instrument that we use in our
laboratory to help with the library
preparation if we're doing the whole
genome sequencing all we have to do with
library preparation because we want to
sequence the entire genomes so all we
need to do is our sequencing primers and
our barcodes and then we're ready for
sequencing so that's one of the main
reasons why we've used genome and others
have used genome sequencing from rapid
secret
thing because even though your
sequencing more so we're seeing this
whole genome the sample preparation is
actually very short if you're doing
anything less than that so any if you
take the whole genome minus one gene
only which we wouldn't do but as an
example you need to do something called
enrichment and this is more targeted
panels and whole exome sequencing come
in and this really is involving
selecting out specific regions of
interest for sequencing so those 571
genes were saying this is all we want to
look at and we used capture probes to
grab the areas that we want to sequence
and then we discard the rest that we
don't want to sequence we do these for
multiple reasons but some are cost and
time considerations so if we're
sequencing less then that means that we
can per sample that means we can put
more samples together and so then that
becomes more efficient from a time
perspective we also are able to pull
samples together for our enrichment so
we take example of those unique barcodes
and that allows us to mix samples
together so we can have up to 12 sample
12 exomes and a single tube for
preparation which makes easier on the
laboratory side so this is decreasing
the cost because we're doing samples
together in one tube and we could
sequence more on a single on a single
instrument but we also get decreased
time for the collection so if you are
just doing one sample than a genome
would be would be faster but if you want
to sequence 12 12 people at a time or 96
people at a time then it's much faster
to do two XO limit of them together down
below what we're showing is really kind
of just an example of how our enrichment
strategies work or how everybody's
enrichment strategies work so here's the
depiction of an exome the black bars are
the exons that we want to sequence and
then up above you see where we've tiled
over those capture bates so the areas
that are complementary and what they're
going to do is we're going to grab those
three exons that we want to sequence and
here we don't want to sequence this last
one and so we don't have any base so
that means when we go to wash and
discard our supernatant we'll get rid of
that and we won't have to sequence out
on the sequencer so after our
preparation so whether we do library
target or whether we do genome
targeted panel or exome them are ready
for sequencing and so within our Center
we're fortunate to have 5 pi/6 ranging
from high stick two thousand all the way
up to a high C 4000 and this enables us
to have pretty broad sequencing
capabilities and that we can do one
genome and 25 hours on one instrument
all the way up to doing 16 genomes and
three days on that 4,000 on one single
instrument we also have to my seats that
we use for sequencing these are smaller
instruments they be sustained sequencing
chemistry though and so these allow us
to do for tags can samples so again
that's at small panel and about 30 hours
per my seeks we could do eight at a time
if we run both instruments so sample
preparation sequencing are really only
one part and one small part of the
process of other critical one but what
we really have is a critical need for
bioinformatics and so I often feel like
the person in this cartoon and then I'm
really good at sample preparation
sequencing and generating the raw data
and that a whole bunch of stuff happens
on our computers that then give me the
data to be able to do the analysis so to
be able to support that stuff all of the
computer that needs to compute that
needs to happen we have a large
bioinformatics team has developed a
suite of custom software and so one of
the things that we need to do when we
first get our sequencing or when the
data first comes off of that sequencers
that will need to be able to take that
raw data and turn it in two variants
that we can annotate and so what I'm
showing here the white bar across the
top is our reference genome and below
that those a hundred base pair I'm
segment a representative of what a
single read what might be from a
sequencing or patient that we've
sequenced and so after the data comes
off the sequencer and we do our calling
to find out what our variants are what
we have to do is take that data take
those weeds and we align them back to
the reference genome and that allows us
then to compare and say yes this person
is wild-type they match the reference or
know this person actually got to change
as you can see here where they have a
heterozygous change from the reference
sequence and so what this is allowing us
to do then is identify all the places in
the genome where our person is different
after that after we identified all the
places where we have a variant from the
reference what we then need to do is use
our software to characterize so that we
understand whether this is just a common
change or is it the change that we want
to look more into is it in a gene or is
it in between a gene and give us all
that information that enables us to do
the analysis so another one of the last
things I wanted to talk about about
sequencing and what you'll hear
reference many times when you're looking
at sequencing is sequencing coverage and
this is what's describing the average
number of reads the line to recover
known reference basis so in the previous
slide you saw that there are multiple
reads that were toiling over a single
base and as you cover or read over a
single position more times so the base
calls can be made with a higher degree
of confidence so it's the same thing as
if you read the slide five times you
would have a better feeling or feel more
confident that you knew what was on the
slide is if you'd only glanced over at
once this is particularly important as
we think about things are and how
outside the box of inherited and dealing
disease such as cancer where we have
somatic changes where you might have
cancer chrome is only there saying five
percent of the DNA and so you need to
read over that same position multiple
times so that you can catch the changes
that on a lower level it's also
important because in contrast to sing or
sequencing next-gen still has inherent
era traits and that means the
probability that at any given base is
the right call and what that's what's a
score that we use is called a quality
score of q30 and what that's saying to
us is that there's only a one in a
thousand chance the nucleotide call us
and corrects so while most of us would
be fairly confident and would bet on
those odds it's still better practice to
read over multiple times so that you
have a higher confidence in making that
base call and so at the end of the day
the gene is covered on genome on the
genome which it would be covered on XM
and on cat scan the difference between
them then is really your coverage and so
targeted panels are allowing for deeper
sequencing so you're going to
eat over at baseman more times with less
overall data so standard coverage for a
genome would be 30 x and that really
tends to be the minimum at most people
use you're going to read over every base
thirty times an X on one average you're
going to read over the basis that you
want to sequence 80 times and when we
get down to our targeted panel only 571
genes we're going to read over it over
200 times so what does this look like in
real data so this is just a picture of
the Cystic Fibrosis gene cftr which is
one of the most common inherited
diseases and in northern North America
in the US and so here we're just showing
you all the horizontal purple lines here
are the exons of the gene it's a fairly
large gene and so when we think of that
those are all the exons that we're going
to want to cover when we're sequencing
and so here I've showed your
representative coverage over the same
exact area in both the tag scan and
exo-m in a genome so you can see on the
bottom in the genome that we have nice
even coverage completely across that
region you will see a small little gap
in the coverage and that's because even
with genome sequencing their areas that
are very repetitive that are difficult
for the technology to go through you can
see then in the exo-m and tagged scan
that we have these humps of coverage
over the exons and so these are areas
that we wanted to enrich and that we
have nice deep coverage on you can see
in tags beyond which was a second hump
that's not in the exomes oh and this is
an area that is that there's an intronic
change that we know is pathogenic and so
because we custom designed this panel
we're able to go in and say hey we need
to get this area to this excellent data
that I'm showing you is just an
excellent the shelf so it's designed to
cover all the genes so it didn't have
that intergenic that intronic a step to
cover
so when we zoom in closer we can see
over the exact same position when I say
coverage changes we read over the same
position that tank scan over 200 times
we read over it in the exome about 72
times and we read over that same
position about 30 times in the genome so
again it's how many times coverage is
how many times did you go over that same
region to gain confidence in that call
that's one of the main difference in the
different types of testing so as you
might imagine if you're looking at
different numbers of variants or
different numbers of genes you're going
to get very different numbers of
variance to look at an analysis of
next-generation sequencing data has been
described is finding a needle and a
stack of needles when my favorite quotes
and so from taxi on and 571 genes what
we get is that on average 8,000 variance
for us to look through and analyze an
exome can be anywhere up to 300,000
variants and a whole genome can produce
up to 4 million variants none of us have
the time to sit and look through even
8,000 variants let alone four million
variants so again this is where software
is going to come in and tell us and help
us narrow down which variants are just
normal population changes and which
variants are rare and in gene that we
need to look at and might be potentially
pathogenic so this is again where our
software suite that our Center has
developed comes in into play and so this
is for our variant annotation
classification analysis and I'll go
through what these are doing and show
how this works but ruins is our first
one its forebear and annotation saga is
mapping our clinical symptoms to gene so
that's giving us a short list of genes
for us to look at and then biking is
that final piece that's going to
integrate all of our DSO are
characterized variants with our
prioritized gene list and allow us to
look through it in real time the rooms
we like acronyms in our Center is the
rapid understanding of nucleotide
variant effects software and for every
single barrier that we see what ruins is
doing is it's going through and giving
us information about that variant so
it's telling us how frequent have we
seen it or how novel is it have we seen
it in two thousand of the samples we
sequence internally or have we seen it
only once it goes out looks at public
database
such as DB sniff we look at exact and
also a thousand genomes we also pull in
things like hgmd another thing that
we've look at and that is Ben is very
important or helpful for us in our
analysis is our ACMG categorization and
so this categorization is one that's
been put forth by the American College
of medical genetics and it helps us to
take all of our bearings and put them in
large buckets which make it easier for
analysis so category one for example is
a variant that's been previously
reported when and recognize the causes
disorder so an example might be Delta F
508 as cystic fibrosis we've seen that
variant and we know that even though
it's common it's very its associated
with classics Tia category two are novel
variants so they haven't been seen
before and but they're the type expected
to cause a disorder so these are things
like a premature stop codon a loss of
the initiation so affecting the start or
frame shift or nonce experience so it's
easy to interpret how those changes in
that gene or how the changes are
affecting the gene category three are
novel so we they're not very frequent
but it's hard they may or may not be
positive so this is where our missin
sperience are coming into play are in
frame insertions or deletions and then
category pores are really novel but
probably not positive so these are
probably population changes you can
imagine that as each bucket so category
1 is the smallest bucket category 2 gets
bigger category 3 there are more
variants that fall into that so as you
increase in category increase in variant
numbers so i mentioned that we're able
to use saga which is symptom and sign
assisted genome analysis as a way to
take the phenotype that's described from
the patient from the clinic and make
that turn that into a gene less to
prioritize for analysis and this is a
test roaring interface that integrates
with the electronic medical record and
again it's mapping those clinical
features two and two genetic diseases to
genes and I'm really it's serving
multiple functions but three of them as
I mentioned are denominated super set of
genes for analysis and then because most
of our analysis is in p
in the pediatric population we have to
think about incidental findings and
guidelines for testing and children and
so this is a way for us to restrict our
analyses to G only genes that are
associated right these are known to be
associated with that phenotype and that
look at jeans that have absolutely no
connection it also is helping us we
again take those 8,000 those 300,000
variants and get a smaller list that's
more manageable to go through for
analysis and so again because most of
our testing is in children we also from
hygienic counseling standpoint we need
to be we think about how we're doing our
testing and how it impacts our patients
and traditionally if you look at genetic
testing there's been really there was
previously a mandate to avoid violating
a child's right to an open future so as
an adult I may want to know that I have
an increased risk of Alzheimer's disease
so I can be screened more often or I
might make changes in my diet or
exercise whatever I might feel is
necessary but a child may not want to
know that and if we told them that
information as a child if they didn't
want to know that they can't unknown
information so really we've tried to not
tell children genetic testing results
that's not impacting their fair mediate
care and allow them to make that
decision when they reach adulthood so
this is compacted things like our test
design hints dhaga it also helps us has
impacted how we approach testing and
whether we need consent for testing and
how we're giving back those results of
the communication some of the things
that we use to help us again is that
that's where clinical panels can be
useful so you're only looking at disease
associated genes or genes that are
associated at phenotypes and such as tag
scan which is 571 genes or our exomes we
offer as symptom driven exomes meaning
that we're only going to look at the
genes that are known to be associated
with their features again the last piece
of the puzzle is our Viking so barring
an integration and knowledge
interpretation genomes and this again is
a way for us integrate that saga and
bruins data it also allows us again to
prioritize those variants and
importantly it's allowing us to filter
on the frequency of the Iberian so we
keep track about both internally in our
own internal warehouse and also we use
again
public databases such as exact and as
well as inheritance filtering so now I
think the best way to understand how
this information is being used in clinic
is to use some case examples and so this
is a case example of tags in our panel
so our very first case that was referred
to the symptom are to the center when we
first started where cmh one and two and
these were sisters with progressive
ataxia so at the time they were sent to
the genome center for sequencing the
first sibling the older sibling was 9
years old in the second the second
sister was five the first dling had
normal delay she did have disordered
movements and had a taxi at onset about
the age of four to five years which had
resulted in her being wheelchair reliant
by eight years of age and by six years
of age they have noticed that she had a
progressive cerebellar atrophy now the
second the younger sister again had mild
delays in early development her a taxi
on said it two years it's not clear
entirely if she's more severely affected
over it's just that when she have one
affected child and you're more tuned to
symptoms that may have been in the first
child you just weren't looking for them
um but she also was noted to have
progressive cerebellar atrophy this is
an MRI from one of the children and so I
am NOT a neurologist myself but I think
it's very clear that there is them if
you look at the MRIs that you can see
the cerebellar atrophy in these children
is quite striking so before they had
gotten to the genome center for
sequencing these this family had had
five years since that first initial
diagnosis with no with no diagnosis and
it because we had spent over twenty
three thousand dollars in testing and
this really included the gamut of all
clinically very appropriate testing from
a karyotype to microarray to specific
single gene testing for something such
as a taxi at telangiectasia down to the
biochemical and bindings to try to see
if we could get a biochemical diagnosis
for the family so we like to see or we
describe as family as being in a
diagnostic crossroads when they got to
the center
so this is how saga is working again
saga is being applied to tag skin so 571
genes so if we put in the term ataxia
out of those 571 genes we've now come
down to 78 genes if we put in a second
symptom from this family of a
developmental disorder of motor function
we have 44 jeans you can see there's
some overlap in the genes between ataxia
and develop knowledge sort of motor
function and if we put in a third
feature and saga this is nominating 28
jeans again there's some overlaps with
muscle atrophy if we look at the
intersection of all three of these we
actually come down to a single gene of
apt x so when we did the sequencing the
family did actually have were found to
have a homozygous the sisters mutation
in April and aptx on this mutation stops
the a protection protein from being made
and the parents there is known content
waiting as family were found to be
carriers of the mutation and so we
immediately before we even ran the test
we were able to use saga to get down to
one single candidate gene to start with
and that's where in this family we will
define the mutation now of course
they're not always this clean but I
think this is a very good illustration
of how we're able to use software to
with our analysis the same things can be
applied to exome sequencing and so we
initially offered exome sequencing only
on a research basis within our Center
and so one of the things that we did
before we turned it on clinically is
that we looked at the clinical utility
of next-gen sequencing and
neurodevelopmental disorders and we took
the first 100 families that were
enrolled in our research biorepository
which included a hundred nineteen
patients and this was actually published
almost eighteen months ago and Science
Translational Medicine by a student at
all what we found in lucky those first
100 families is at forty-five percent of
the children that had been followed an
ambulatory care received diagnosis after
exome or genome sequencing and the cost
of the testing prior to any of the
next-gen test was nineteen thousand one
hundred per family and this suggested
that exome or genome sequencing would be
cost-effective at up to seven thousand
six hundred dollar six hundred dollars
per family which is the cost that's
easily attainable for exomes I'm in the
current state of those families a change
in the clinical care impression of the
pathophysiology was supported in half of
those diagnosed families that's huge so
in half of our cases that got a
diagnosis their clinical care was
impacted and had we performed exome or
genome sequencing and got a diagnosis at
the onset of symptoms we may have made a
diagnosis on average 77 months earlier
than I occurred in the study it's almost
six years which again for a family think
about the journey they had been on with
no answer that's critically important
for them another thing that we looked at
is what are the inheritance patterns
that we're seeing and this is a
neurodevelopmental disorder and we had a
wide range of diagnosis but we were
somewhat to price at the time Mikey novo
dominant were the most common and for
our studies for our genome and exomes we
try to sequence the trio meaning the
affected patient and appearance when
they're available as often as possible
and that's giving us a strength to find
those de novo variants that you wouldn't
be able to categorize without the
parents and this is broadly applicable
though well beyond neurodevelopmental so
we're seeing this more and more that
noble dominant disease is much more
common than we initially thought after
that we saw things that you would
predict such as heterozygous autosomal
recessive disease dominant disease and
then mitochondrial so again I think a
case can tell you and easily or
illustrate how does this change or is it
directly impacting our patient so case
too was a 13 year old male who had
fallen at home and complained of back
pain subsequently he developed numbness
and tingling and was presented to
emergency room and x-rays revealed
multiple compression fractures is spine
which is not something that you would
see in a child typically who just Falls
his bone density score revealed severe
osteoporosis with the z-score minus four
point seven so that's quite significant
and the patient had reported a history
of three arm fractures previously with
appropriate trauma so we'd fallen just
doing normal boy things but there is no
report of low bone mineral content or
osteopenia on any of his prior ski
so he was sent for evaluation and
collagen 181 and 182 gene sequencing
were ordered appropriately for
osteogenesis imperfecta and of course
the results came back with a variant of
unknown significance so this is the
intronic variant that hadn't been seen
before and so they've had it was they
had homicides that it might be affecting
splicing so parental testing for the
variance they tested both parents for
this variant indicators de novo although
i will say that parental identity was
not confirmed not that it was there was
any suspicion but something to think
about when you're looking at the noble
testing so the laboratory reported this
back as a variant of unknown
significance but clinically it was then
interpreted as pathogenic and this
family was given a diagnosis for this
patient of oh I type 1 however as the
child was being followed the treating
physician subsequent treating position
was not convinced that this variant was
the answer and really didn't feel like
they felt the profile of I oh I and so
the patient and his mother were extent
for whole exome sequencing so what we
found what interestingly on whole exome
sequencing is that the patient and his
mother both carried a heterozygous 14
Bass Pro deletion and the pls 30 + + 3
gene the results in a frameshift in a
premature stop and this is a relatively
new gene but it's a differential of both
osteogenesis imperfecta and its
associated with osteoporosis fractures
develop and childhood and high
permeability importantly and a change
from a denoble disease is that this deep
in this disease which is excellent
carrier women can range from normal bone
density to early onset osteoporosis and
fractures this is an example of our
warehouse page where it's giving us a
little more information about that
variant and this is again what ruins is
spitting out so at the time this was
saying that we had seen this in only two
samples which was the patient and his
mother it's x-linked in our patient was
male so that's why one was homozygous
the gene again is plastine three and
then it gives us the transcript and how
it's affecting the gene here this is a
program called igb
just put out by the road and this is
what allows us to visualize you again
you can see that the patient on top is
homozygous for the deletion that black
bar in the middle of the reeds and the
mom is heterozygous for the deletion
this is just a screenshot showing some
of the features associated with class
and 3 and how well it fits and overlaps
with this family so it's excellent
dominant they can have osteopenia
osteoporosis multiple fractures after
trauma vertebral compression fractures
and long room factors after minor trauma
so after doing the exome sequencing
entitlements clinicians this family was
given I think the correct diagnosis now
molecular diagnosis if pls three related
osteoporosis now the mother is a carrier
of this and again remember mothers can
be some can be symptomatic and so for
her we recommended early screening for
osteoporosis he does have a sister
that's not had any fractures but we'll
offer testing to her she's been offered
testing determine her genotype because
again females can have some
manifestations of disease and it also
results in a pretty big recurrence risk
change in his family so before what was
thought to be de novo dominant so we
would have told the parents they had
very little chance for recurrence and we
told the patient that he had a fifty
percent chance at the time he decided to
have children if he did we've now
changed and that it's excellent and so
our patient has a chance of having only
carrier and females and unaffected sons
but now we need to talk to the whole
family because there's other members at
risk for having either osteopenia or
having affected children now in this
case the family was actually very happy
with the change in recurrent stress
because it decreased the risk and the
probe and even though it increased risk
for other family members I think more
than anything this is really
highlighting how before with the
traditional medicine when we're doing
thing or sequencing and gene by Gene you
only found what you were looking for so
we only looked in college and 181 and
182 that's what we knew to look for and
we found something but when we opened up
and look beyond the streetlight so we
looked in the areas that were previously
dark we saw out this is actually a much
better diagnosis are much better fit and
we've seen that quite often in our our
family and in patients that have been
sent where the initial diagnosis just
doesn't quite make sense or it's a
variant of unknown significance that
we're trying to get some more
information on think it's particularly
applicable and this is one of the
reasons why our Center is within a
pediatric hospital as I'm in Pediatrics
when you're early and disease
progression so when those children are
first presenting the clinic they often
have incomplete sentence there early in
development and so you can have a
stereotyped adaptation to challenges so
if it's a metabolic disorder if you
haven't accumulated those damaging
metabolites very long you won't have the
same disease as someone who's had the
disease for eight years or maybe they
shouldn't be talking so you don't know
that they won't be able to talk we're
increasingly recognizing genetic
heterogeneity so several genes are
causing the same phenotypic disease
where before we thought there was one
gene one disease we're also seeing
increasingly just very poorly defined
clinical heterogeneity there's only two
people in the world that have been
described with the disease I think it's
fair to say quite a bit of confidence
that we don't have a fully understanding
of all the symptoms that could possibly
be associated with that disease or that
gene I'm justina copies that I think
another thing that most people can agree
on is that an early diagnosis will give
us the best chance for an optimal
outcome so the earlier we understand the
disease we understand the gene and the
pathways that gives us the best chance
of finding a treatment or working and
getting the proper interventions for
that child and at a minimum that would
give the families or can empower the
families and looking at family planning
so I also wanted to briefly talk on
genome sequencing so I think it really
more than anything in addition to
excellence but it's highlighting how
research and clinical or working
together so as I mentioned we have we do
offer clinical whole genome testing and
this requires consent by a genetic
counselor to discuss incidental finding
options so the American College of
medical genetics is put out a list of 56
genes that they recommend be offered
all families undergoing full exome
sequencing or genome sequencing and
these are primarily cardiomyopathy genes
or cancer genes but they have the option
of getting results if there's a known
pathogenic change it's been seen in
those that we could report back to them
as a sinner we've been offering this for
almost a year about 10 months we run
genomes on the child and ex them on the
parents and in only 10 months within
only our Center we've done clinical
sequencing on 52 programs which i think
is pretty amazing because we go through
a pretty certification process with
insurance but I think if we're looking
at our testing in our clinical and our
research in our genome is that they're
actually not that different after all so
in our clinical practice we want to
diagnose patients we want to target our
treatment we want to avoid unnecessary
treatments and tests and we want to
educate patients and offer genetic
counseling on the research side we want
to do all of these things too but we
also want to discover genes and
phenotypes we want to develop drugs
treatments we want to innovate so we
want to look at new test methods and we
also want to illuminate disease state
pathophysiology I don't think you can
really have that research component now
and the Arab genome sequencing when you
have clinical sequencing because what we
can see our what does happen all the
time is that you will see changes in a
gene that maybe the gene hasn't been
annotated before or been reported in
humans but there's certainly evidence to
make it suspicious that this could be
the disease phenotype so we need a way
and we're all working on ways to better
do those functional studies and get the
data so that we can report that back
clinically so one of the components to
for our research and genome is that
we're looking at the application of
rapper genome sequencing in the NICU so
this is that static project and this is
where we can routinely do it a genome
and 50 hours under our research protocol
and so again in the NICU when we have
critically ill children that are
presented this can be effective to
diagnose or rule out known mutations
because both are important and and the
idea is that if we can do that at this
start will reduce unnecessary tests can
be useful and other testing and again
we're going to cast that wide net to
find it
really we were the first one in the
world to do these emergency genomes the
result of this work is that where a key
site in a u19 grant that offers
enrollment of up to 800 babies the worst
and we're randomizing that to
experimental control we're half we are
going to get the rapid genome on how
forgetting standard of care which is
going to allow us to see the clinical
utility again of what if we offered
clinical genomes in a rapid state and
under a rapid basis in our in our NICU
it also is including some psychosocial
assessment and one-year follow-up so
again a case speaks a thousand words so
case three was one of our static cases
and this was a baby that had a history
of hypoglycemia with a glucose level of
18 they were transferred at one month of
age to our Center and again we were
still having difficulty managing my
glucose and they were the fourth child
born to 27 year old parents with no one
with similar concerns and really in no
contributory family history and they
also had a normal a newborn screen and
at the time because we were unable to
control the glucose they were
considering a total of pingaree tecta me
so in as I'm looking at clinically how
they're working with managing these they
consoled a chop for surgery for that
pancreatectomy or partial pancreatectomy
and i said at the time well you're never
going to have your genome results back
and in time for us to use a surgery it
was already scheduled which is like the
gauntlet had been thrown for us so
challenge accepted so we consented them
on the 24th receive the samples not
until a 25th we had a plumber a result
though back by the 28th we ordered our
singer confirmation because of thunder
research we had to clinically confirm
before we can put it back and we had the
final clinical report spine and given
back to them before they went to have
their appropriate surgery at chop and so
what we found in this family is that
they had a heterozygous known pathogenic
variant and ABC CA that was inherited
from dad but we didn't see a second
variant I mean this is classically
related to autosomal recessive disease
except for when it's not and so paternal
inheritance is highly suspicious for
focal disease meaning that there was a
second somatic event that leads to loss
of the maternal will and a
subset of cells so but this results in a
drastically different treatment and
outcome so instead of that total
pancreatectomy which would have led to
life on diabetes the patient had a sub
total pancreatectomy and essentially
they're cured when we looked at our
first 45 affected individuals which is
40 when families we had at the time of
this study when we did it we had 13
families with a confirmed diagnosis we
had three additional that had a partial
diagnosis so they fairly probably had
more than one thing going on eight
families had candidate genes that needed
further work before I could report them
back and we did still have 14 families
with no diagnosis or candidate gene any
of these diagnoses directly impacted
clinical management but sometimes that
impact on clinical management especially
in the NICU is a redirection to
palliative care and that's just as
important as understanding that there
might be a treatment and so I think as
we look at genomic medicine and what
we're doing already I'm kind of to
summarize what I've shown you is that
already we're able to use genomic
medicine to rapidly diagnose our
critically ill patients and to in those
diagnostic Odysseys we're able to
identify those treatable conditions
earlier and that's enabling us to find a
quicker path home for patients we're
able to provide accurate prognostic
information and recurrence risk for our
patients which will enable new or
alternative treatment options so we look
at any one clinical trials and of course
we're always discovering new disease
genes that we're reporting and so I
think genomic medicine is going to is
already changing and how we're managing
our patients and it's just going to
continue to change how we're doing that
I'm hope I've shown you that through
this presentation today so I'd also like
to just take a second to acknowledge our
whole team's again as I mentioned it
takes an entire village to run a genome
center and then there's a link to our
website if you want more information
about our Center so I thank you very
much for attending the webinar and I'd
be happy to answer questions now
thank you dr. Farrell for your
presentation a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them into Q&A box found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
dr. Farrell will answer as many
questions as time permits and the first
question is in a 2013 case study you
linked a to bass player de novo deletion
to substitution of a valine for a
glutamine and microcephaly autism global
developmental delay enemy topic
craniosynostosis our base paired
deletions also linked from Zika virus to
morphological and behavioral phenotypes
by amino acid substitutions at super
familiar with the Zika viruses so I
sorry let me start over I'm actually not
familiar with the Zika virus and how it
may or may not be interacting it's
probably not through base pair deletions
although viruses are known to be able to
mutate themselves pretty rapidly that's
how they get resistance two different
treatments
as differential splicing results can
take some time how can mgs use show both
split splice specific and environmental
issues in pediatric diseases splicing um
that's a great question and what I
didn't touch on our go over is something
called RNA seek so what RNA seek enables
us to do is actually sequence the RNA or
the message RNA and so we can use that
that's actually a very powerful tool for
assessing novel transcripts so if we
have a splicing change that we think is
changing whether an exon is spliced in
or out you can actually use RNA seek and
that allows us to check those
alternative transcripts one of the
limits of that is that it has to be a
gene what it's expressed in a to show
that we're able to get to so we can
easily give blood from our patients but
many genes especially we look at
neurodevelopmental aren't expressed in
the blood so that's one of the
limitations but as we look at trying to
function characterize especially are
slicing variants that's the first thing
that we we do is we look to see can we
get RNA from an appropriate tissue and
then that allows us to look at the
splicing
did you prove functionally that these
variants you found or the real causative
of the disease so foreign else is what
we do is that we follow the ACE the
American College of medical genetics is
also put out dropped guidelines for the
interpretation of pathogenicity
invariance and we follow that those
guidelines for our clinical reporting
back so in some cases if someone else
has done the worker it's very clear for
example some genes are known or
characterized by de novo base pair of
changes in the gene then that we don't
need to do additional functional studies
because the background of knowledge is
already there in the cases where we have
either a novel mutation in a known gene
or we have a novel mutation in a novel
gene yes we do undertake those
functional studies either ourselves or
through collaborations to help prove and
give ourselves the body of data that we
need to then give it back and report it
to the patients so that's where you'll
see some case reports that come out or
collaboration so it takes a mix of both
21
can we depend on the genomic data
especially if they are novel to take a
clinical decision specifically in cases
that need prompt interventions so I
think that I think the question is how
are we using the data to guide our
clinical or what steps are taken again
we're relying on the ACMG before we
report that back if someone's in a
research study then of course they need
to follow all clinical care as they
standardly were or what in case if the
research study didn't exist when we find
novel changes on our in our clinical
studies or new changes that weren't
expected things that we often do is that
we have case conferences or if we have
called a calls or meetings and I where
people are located to really discuss and
work through with the positions like
this is what we see on our side this is
what you know the molecular genetics is
telling us what do you see in the clinic
and we can work through that together to
see are there other things that we
should be looking for their other tests
that we should be doing to confirm that
and so neither the clinic nor the lab is
operating a silo in our institution I
think that's one of our strengths that
we work together do you teach students
to differentiate between mutations and
amino acid substitutions
sure so we actually use those terms
often interchangeably so a mutation or a
variant just means any change that we
see in the genome that's different from
the reference so that could be anything
what can sometimes happen is that in our
code so in that central dogma of DNA RNA
protein when we're coding or the amino
acid are three codons DNA is coding for
a specific amino acid what can happen is
that sometimes the change and the DNA
can cause a change and that amino acid
so you may go from an alanine to a
baleen sometimes that can happen that
you have a silent change and that you
have a nucleotide change but it's not
changing an amino acid so all variants
are mutations but not all mutations
result in amino acid change
what are your two NGS Instruments has
better QA q s in terms of quicker
treatments and cheaper cost so if I
understand the question correctly you're
asking what are some quality things or
measures that we put in place and ways
to make it cheaper and quicker to move
into the clinic on some of those changes
that come about our outside of our
control so that a new instrument such as
the 4000 is able to produce more data in
less time so that enables us to put more
people together or more samples together
on a single run we have pretty stringent
quality control metrics on our side that
would ease universally and so those of
anything are going to slow us down but I
think they're pretty critically
important to make sure that we have the
right data coming through the other
things that we're looking at is we're
always looking at ways that we can use
either automation to help us with sample
preparation are there ways that we can
change the sample preparation methods
ourselves to make them go faster and so
again we're using a combination of
different factors to cut our times down
the other thing that there's seen a
pretty dramatic change in so not only in
this sequencing time but in the analysis
the compute time so where it used to
take us to an entire day for a genome to
be annotated we can now do in as little
and under an hour if we need to and so
that's another place that you don't
often think about a big decrease in time
but that as well as others are working
on getting at informatics side down and
faster as well
did you have a case where sequencing
information was not helpful or led to
confusion of course we definitely have
pieces where we either don't have the
diagnosis and so particularly if we've
run a whole genome that can be very
difficult for someone to understand that
while you looked at everything you're
telling it must not be genetic which
isn't the case it just means that we
don't know where it we just weren't able
to find it or sometimes what can happen
to is that we'll see something that we
on the lab side say wow this this team
is really suspicious to us and then and
the clinic side they'll sail just
doesn't make sense of what I'm seeing
and so again that's the strength of us
being able to go back and forth but we
have some variants that we're just not
sure and so they get bucketed and into
that buried of unknown significance and
they kind of sit there until we either
have more patience or we have a
publication or you know we start seeing
it in someone else oh my gosh these
people don't match up at all it must not
be it I would like to
again thank dr. Farrell for her
presentation do you have any final
comments for us today I just want to
thank everyone for listening I hope that
I've shown you the power of
next-generation sequencing and how it
can be applied in clinic and I hope that
I've excited you as much as we are about
how we're using it to help our
population and looking forward to all
the changes that are going to come in
the future thanks again I'd also like to
thank the audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions this
is an educational webinar and thus
offers free continuing education credits
after the webinar is over and to get
your credits click on the button located
in the bottom left hand corner of your
web page the webcast this webcast can be
viewed on demand through November 11th
2016 lab roots will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who have made may have
missed today's live event until next
time goodbye